many of us especially here at mit have
felt the pressure to be perfect to
always be at a hundred percent uh to
push yourself into giving your best
effort again and again even when things
like this happen
uh we may wait for conditions to be just
right to have the best environment for
the best work
and of course this can manifest as
many different things
one of them can be this drive to collect
things
uh to preserve things to
save an expensive journal for the
perfect project and then end up never
using it for its purpose
we can end up assigning perhaps undo
weight and meaning to objects making
them precious and to be revered rather
than use them for what they are
under such weight it is no surprise that
people find destroying things so
cathartic and satisfying there's a
pleasure in setting yourself free
psychologically while also being
released physically we burn homework at
the end of the year we smash dishes that
were different by toxic relative we
crush cars that seem to break down
rather vindictively uh humans have been
using similar rituals for cleansing and
transition for ages their physical
mental and spiritual power have stood
the test of time
games have evolved alongside ritual and
other innately human practices like
storytelling games create this altered
state of mind a game space where you
follow arbitrary rules and overcome
self-imposed challenges
often you build this special little
world with your fellow players by
agreeing on boundaries and demonstrating
your understanding of the world's
conventions violating these social
conventions can often be more severe
than breaking game rule
one of the more recent offerings to the
game space are legacy games which
emphasize the heavyweight associated
with permanent impactful decisions
because the style of game is relatively
new the definition is still muddy but
there is a common agreement that they
have multiple sessions they demand
players make impactful decisions that
forever alter the game and players are
unable to play the same game a second
time
and then i'll get more into the specific
definition that i'm using for my
research a little bit later
on so for this presentation i'm going to
hit a few key points for my research
i'll start by drawing some more explicit
links between rituals and games and how
rituals can inspire game design
next i'll move on to why explain
to why examining legacy games is
becoming increasingly relevant
and especially important for game design
and media studies as a whole
then i'll highlight what existing legacy
games have contributed to innovation in
game design as well as what is still
missing
next i'll explore how legacy games can
be brought to another level and how they
can help us reframe what games uh and
playing them looks like
then i'll get into my playtesting uh and
what i learned about the power of
integrating ritual elements in a game
and spoiler there's fire and destruction
uh finally i'll get into the impact of
the research and thoughts about the
future of the legacy game genre
so first connections between rituals and
games
there's significant overlap between
rituals and games games are performed as
part of rituals like the olympic games
and there are ritualistic elements to
games
the rock paper scissors chant and its
action is
a very familiar ritual of faith for a
lot of us
still it is possible to create a
dichotomy by associating games with the
binaries of victory and defeat and
ritual with equality and wholeness i
find it more helpful for research and
game design to put them on the same
spectrum would follow that games that
don't divide players into winners and
losers would lean closer to rituals on
this game's ritual spectrum
so why not lean into that when designing
draw inspiration from these parallel
practices
so next why i'm looking at legacy games
and why now
board games have always evolved to
follow the eras and the money reflecting
our values and views of leisure time
as gamers interest in tabletop
role-playing games like dnd and
warhammer grew and euro games like
settlers of catan followed suit the
investment and game components did as
well
players could have boxes of lovingly
painted minis detailed maps and get more
bang for their buck from the same game
especially as kickstarter came on scene
games got bigger boxes expensive
components and demand more shelf space
for many a board gamer is synonymous
with board game collector and for avid
collectors there can be anxiety around
preserving their expensive investment
they might they may buy two copies one
to leave unopened and one to play with
gentle careful clean hands
but as people are forced to move to find
work or downsides to save money it
becomes clear that 450 pound boxes of
board games is just not sustainable
instead when we look to the future of
board games we are turned to other kind
of experiential games with fewer
mechanics and components kind of like
escape rooms which are growing in
popularity
exploring legacy games is so relevant
now because they reflect our current
need for collaborative experiences that
give us permission to play around and
break things
there's something so freeing about not
having to be careful to play like you
did as a kid without any worry about
making a mess
next looking at the innovations and
limitations of legacy games that led to
the recent surge in popularity
these vanguard legacy games have taught
us a lot about striving to upset the
norms of board gaming in pursuit of the
ever better game
still they have set unnecessary
limitations that have narrowed the
design space and stifled the
rule-breaking attitude they had when
first imagining what legacy games could
be
first the key contributions legacy games
started with this grand vision of
blurring the line between the real world
and the game world
no reset no save only your decision your
decisions permanently changing the game
as you physically change it too
playing in this liminal space uh allows
designers to reorient
a gameplay experience around narrative
and reflection rather than winning and
losing
more attention can also be paid to
creating and destroying the game
artifacts and we can dig into what each
component truly contributes to the
experience do we need these expensive
components how many do we need things
like that
early legacy games helped bring
collaborative world building to the
forefront and expose players to the
freedom of creating a world that
embraces them
and finally legacy games grow to reflect
reflect their players recalling the
nostalgia of opening an old beat up game
box and being flooded with those
memories
even with all these innovations many
legacy game designers hold themselves
back this can be for financial reasons
they take a long time to play tests they
can require lots of narrative content
and the components can be as i mentioned
very expensive
if a customer is going to dish out 60 70
80 100 for a game the thought is that
they're going to want to replay it as
much as possible
as a result of this thinking many
many legacy games especially those from
big name board game companies have shied
away from true destruction
they either design it away altogether
with removable stickers and instructing
players to simply set aside any cards
removed from the game or they include it
but only incidentally opening sealed
envelopes or boxes can feel like
destruction but it's not an essential
fully integrated part of the game i
could just as easily flip to the needed
page on a guide instead of getting new
information from the envelope these
types of legacy games simply rearrange
their components not destroy them
if we want to keep the innovative spirit
that created legacy games we can't be
satisfied with dancing around
destruction and offering destruction
light to players we should reorient
design thought around what makes legacy
games special in the first place choices
with meaningful permanent changes to the
game and its components in my definition
of legacy game these changes are the
keystone of the entire genre
so how can we make destruction a vital
fully integrated part of a legacy game
well first we should expand our idea of
what games and playing them looks like
there's a sense that legacy games are
destroying something and of course i use
that terminology as well but i use it in
the context of simultaneously creating
something
the process of transforming elements of
the game is the game an act of deletion
is still part of the overall story
we see this theme a lot in performance
and conceptual art media that has always
inspired us to examine our idea of what
art looks like
and in process art the act of destroying
a black canvas with paint is more
important than the finished piece
process over product
this idea of embracing destruction as an
experience is an important but
underutilized tool for legacy game
designers
and while we're re-examining our
understanding of destruction we can
re-examine what is meant by legacy as i
mentioned earlier legacy games can be
understood as the intersection of game
ritual and storytelling
while legacy more broadly can be
understood as the interplay of the past
present and future
wisdom of the past is dynamic always
evolving to suit the needs of the
current generation always reinforcing a
connection to what came before and how
it guides us in the present to shape our
future legacy games could do the same
they already blur the space between the
game world and the real world so why not
time as well how can we explore this
concept of legacy within a legacy game
so on to my favorite part game
development and play testing
and i have a couple of materials that i
do want to pass out
just to give an idea of what i've been
doing
you can kind of take them and pass them
back
uh
all right
so i went into the design with a few
goals based on my prior research
primarily examining both the physical
action of creating and destroying as
well as the experiential aspect compared
to previous legacy games i wanted to
lean into the destruction while also
embracing board games shift to
experiences
secondary goals i kept in mind either
because uh the literature suggested them
like ritual and performance and
discussion and reflection or because i
was personally curious about them like
enduring and ephemeral artifacts and
collaborative world building and
something i personally have not seen a
lot in games death not as a punishment
but as part of the process of moving
forward
so a basic overview of the game so far
after about a dozen or so play tests
first players pick a band of families
that they'll represent each one has
unique abilities that can they can use
to contribute to the community
next they create a handful of banned
members that represent the current
leader and whoever will succeed them
then players lay out their face down
encounter cards for the session pick a
unique ink color and perform a
fingerprinting ritual they take turns
trying to touch as many of the cards as
possible one hand at a time
and then stack the cards and start the
journey by dripping water and paint on
the starting spot and swirling it around
to make a path their next location is
anywhere on that path
each new location flips an encounter
card which presents a community and
leader challenge
everyone's abilities contribute to the
community score but only the leaders
with their fingerprints on the back of
that card contribute to the leader score
so we have an emphasis on community as
well as your individual contribution
if they succeed in both challenges they
fill out the card to name and describe
the place creature or event that they
encountered
if leaders fail a challenge sacrifice
themselves or die for any reason the
card is immediately burned on the pyre
after this funeral rite that leader's
band will have access to the abilities
gained over their lifetime passing the
wisdom on to the next generation
critically there's no way to level up
your abilities without a leader first
earning them and then dying in order to
guide the band from the beyond the
community is only as strong as its
collective ancestral wisdom
at the end of each session players
perform a tattooing ritual by etching a
design onto their scratch-off
silhouettes usually the symbols only had
meaning for the tattooer but some
players really enjoyed fully drawing out
the funniest moments on the back of
their card
they also contribute to the community
chronicle which is an at-a-glance
summary of what they did in that session
that they can look back on as players in
days or years
i had a really great time with all of my
players and i think their quotes are
very good illustration of whether i'm
hitting my design goals so far
my first primary goal having a product
focused aspect that is both enduring and
ephemeral
players really loved having permission
to be playful looking back on the
message they'd made keeping some
components and burning others uh there
was especially a concern about whether
they could actually destroy things which
i constantly had to reinforce that yes
this is the point of the game please
destroy things
my second primary goal a process focused
experience
a big chunk of the interviews players
devoted to describing the feel of the
game and the emotions it provoked
they talked about freedom from
perfection permission to perform badly
and questioning what we think of as the
right way to play a game
for many of the players that weren't
already avid gamers they admitted
letting themselves just play was
stressful in a way but as the game went
on
they were able to let go of some of that
anxiety
then my secondary goals ritual elements
players absolutely loved the
fingerprinting ritual and especially the
funeral plier
discussion and reflection reviews were
mixed some really liked having deep
conversations with each other while
others opted to kind of give a joke
answer and keep the game moving
death is not a punishment one thing that
kept happening was players just falling
over themselves to die and get their
ability points
which was always a hilarious
conversation to listen to
and collaborative world building like
the discussion prompts reviews varied by
group some liked
taking the time to create a rich world
while others wanted to quickly get back
to the action of challenges burning
things and swirling paint around which i
can't say i blame them but
pacing is definitely a big part of what
i'm going to address in the next
iteration
finally impact and looking to the future
i find that the key impact of this work
falls into three categories reframing
redefining and retracing i like
alliteration
so
first reframing this calls attention to
where the future of board games is
headed away from expensive clunky
revered euro style games and towards
games that center on the process of
playing emphasizing the experience
for many when they hear board gamer they
hear board game collector and they
imagine competition victory points long
hours of intense strategy and intricate
rules
legacy games instead ask us to imagine
games with fire with painting with
community world building with lasting
artifacts that reflect every hand that
touched it we can think more deeply
about the purpose of games what we want
from them
and what they give to us
next redefining like any emerging term
the legacy game definition is nebulous
and gets tweaked as more games enter the
space and i want the term to continue
evolving so it can stand independently
as its own genre not settle
into a rut as a sequel to or reskin of
another game
when we redefine legacy to be the ethos
the game is built around
designers are invited to explore the
liminal space created by blurring the
boundary between the real world and the
game world my hope is that this more
philosophical definition of legacy keeps
the design space open-minded and
inspires more meaningful game
experiences
finally retracing even when even when
looking to the future when we're focused
on the cutting edge it's important to
draw inspiration from our history
there's a reason certain practices have
listed the test of time and drawing from
that wisdom can make our games more
impactful
a legacy is active it's how past wisdom
is adapted to help us in the present and
legacy games ask us to look back on our
history find the fun in our practices
and reflect on what builds connection in
a shared world
looking to an idealistic future for
legacy games and games as a whole
i'd like to really further explore the
psychological spiritual and
transformative power of games
anyone who has played a profoundly
moving game like this war of mine knows
how deeply a game can affect you how can
we harness this medium's grip on us to
improve ourselves and our communities
there's this emerging idea of game
designers playing a contemporary soul
guiding role
more deeply intertwining games with
ritual practices and storytelling's role
in preserving culture
games can allow us to test out different
identities play with our roles in
society imagine fantastical and more
equitable worlds and bringing to the
forefront parts of ourselves we might
not otherwise thoroughly examine
this type of very purposeful game design
is critical to me and it gives me hope
for the future of games and especially
the people who play them
and thanks again for sticking with me i
hope i gave you good reasons to think a
little differently about board games
legacy games especially and the
crossover with other media and i can
take some questions
um
yeah
uh so rick's question was about um how
do
like what sort of distribution would
this game have what's who's the audience
um and how to how do they get started
playing um basically
um so this this type of game of course
like there are some mainstream legacy
games like pandemic legacy that um
people play but as i said it's kind of
this legacy light um sort of thing
whereas i think um a game like this
that's a little bit more experimental um
a little bit certainly more niche um i
think would first have to go through a
lot of uh like indie game sort of
players who are already they have an
expectation of this is going to be weird
we're going to embrace the weirdness and
we're going to see how it goes
me personally i wouldn't be necessarily
looking to
design the game for a larger
distribution i think players of this
kind of game will self-select in a way
in that i'm not trying to appeal to them
more they know what they're looking for
and then they can find all of those
things in this type of game
i hope that address addresses your
question
okay right so um just kind of
uh is there is there a group um
that exists and then what sort of space
um is it trying to fill
uh so yeah definitely there are um the
space that is currently being filled a
lot of strategic players who like these
really long
intense sort of
euro style games
they kind of drift towards like pandemic
legacy risk legacy things like that
but i do think that there is
uh people who have this idea of you know
like d d and other kind of campaign
style games um and not really seeing
that as much in uh board games
themselves
um so
these people who you know they want
their decisions to matter they want
things to persist they want the world to
change they want to see you know if i
come back to this town you know there's
that that bar keep who was really nice
to us and she has a kid now and now
we're you know we've built this world um
together and it's actually evolving with
us
and i think that capturing that idea
into a board game um where you're you
know blending the i am changing the game
world while also i'm physically changing
these components um i think is where
this crossover happens and um
you know those people who are looking
for between d and d and like pandemic
legacy this is where they would find um
a game that hopefully they would enjoy
yeah
so we have a question online from miguel
jacobson he says great talk can you
reflect a bit on the tension between
levity and gravitas in relation to the
death is not a punishment design idea
uh yeah
so kind of um
like
making sure i'm understanding this
question um
kind of the lightness of um our regards
to death as opposed to like the
heaviness of of death um
i think that
in this particular game i'm i am trying
to keep a a reflective sort of attitude
but then players can kind of take that
in as light or as heavy of a direction
as they want um so you know i did have
players who you know
they've uh they built up this character
uh they're really attached to this
character they end up having to
sacrifice themselves for the greater
good um and you know everybody pauses
everybody just kind of stands in silence
for a moment they kind of gather
everybody around their little candle and
they have uh someone will say a few
words and um that's that's the more
intense side of some of the players uh
that that i that i tested with whereas i
had some who was oh i died how did i die
i don't know a bee stung us and uh now
i'm dead and here's my knowledge about
not being stung by a bee so they can
kind of uh choose a little bit more um
whether they want to take
death in this very
powerful deep sort of reflective way or
if they want to take it as more
oh it's interesting that
most games you know when you fail you
die whereas this is i need to fail and
or die in order to progress so
as nikki says right the falling over
each other
yes absolutely yes falling over each
other to die always an enjoyable part of
the play test
police you
yes definitely definitely i um
understand what you're saying about this
idea of
um you know if
people are playing a game they're not
used to destroying games uh they kind of
look to the designer because i happen to
be there uh for reassurance of yes
please destroy this this is the point of
the game
and then what happens when i'm not there
when i step away and i give this out to
to people um only the instructions that
i've given them in the box
and whatnot so
definitely um that is going to be
something that i'm going to have to
either what i would like to do is i
would like to make sort of a vlog around
it where i kind of have an introductory
video and like show a lot of the um
action of people burning stuff and
having these really intense
conversations and making their map
especially people were less less averse
to making the map because i already had
them with like um watercolor paper and
everything so they kind of had this this
opening of this is art this is allowed
it's on watercolor paper whereas when i
got to burning things and like oh can i
mark up my character sheet can i you
know write notes on it um it was a
little bit more unclear because that
wasn't there wasn't as easy of an in
into the art sort of world um so i
definitely have to um have either these
videos that really show uh this is the
fun of the game this is the process of
the game you're not destroying the game
you are playing the game that happens to
also be destroying things that's an
important part of the game um so i can
either do that like i said with the
videos or
if i can really get my words together
and write something awesome for the you
know the booklet inside the box um that
might be possible but i'm definitely
more leaning towards this uh
demonstration of the experience to close
that gap
let's talk a little bit about how
the length of the game
intersects with being a legacy game
you feel like your current actions are
not very impactful
or you are able to move faster
is it really the legacy
how do you think about that yeah
definitely that's a great question um
kind of this idea of
thinking about the length of the game
when when do you show players
the effects of their of their choices
how do you make them
understand that each decision has an
impact both in that moment and you know
10 sessions later when they realize oh
because we did this this is also
happening um
or even in that case we did this we had
no idea that this was an important
decision and now we're stuck and can't
finish this game i had a lot of people
who mentioned pandemic legacy too where
this would happen a lot where they would
make an early decision about
like the military route and then realize
many sessions later we can't really win
the game at all because we made this
decision at the beginning and of course
it's very frustrating and something i
want to avoid um and in in
that sort of sense the looking at the
length of it um i've kind of broken it
down into the
complete ten cards um per season and
then you know they walk away and um go
play again and for another season so you
kind of have this progression of years
and seasons um but also um at this point
this current design i don't have
anything
that would
surprise i guess would be the word
players where i'm not going to pull a
twist or i'm not going to uh you know
give them a sudden you know like lol you
picked the terrible choice and now
you're all doomed i don't want to do
that um i want them to feel like the
decision they made
for example there's a card that's
um uh basically two choices of do you
want to get um
one one increase to your coin ability
now or do you want to get two increases
to your point ability in two sessions so
kind of giving them a choice of yes we
could have this immediate um sort of
uh benefit and we need to tackle this
one card just right now so that's the
choice we're gonna make and then maybe
in a couple of sessions they're gonna
realize oh actually it would have been
nice to have that two coins but that's
not gonna stop them either they just
okay we need two coins let's go back to
a swords card let's go back to a cups
card and when we're strong enough again
let's go do that coin um so at least
right now um the
the effect of what you've chosen um
should be clear both in that moment as
well as later on um
and hopefully nothing that that stops
the gameplays that's of course what i
want to avoid above all else
i'm wondering how a person
yeah absolutely i'm talking a little bit
about um this relationship between
losing and legacy games and that's
definitely um
a space where i think
um there is an issue of you know there
are these legacy games that exist that
kind of went this direction of we're
still gonna divide you into winners and
losers um it's not uh me against you but
it's you against the game the game can
be the winner you're the loser you can
be the winner the game's loser um and
that's that's a very fun uh type of game
a lot of people enjoy that and then i'm
kind of looking at
um how do i make it so that there aren't
these winners and losers you're all kind
of building this game together you're
flushing it out together
um and you're not you feel you don't
feel a loss necessarily you feel um
maybe some disappointment of oh man i
wish we had thought that but hey we're
moving forward we've got the guidance
you know of our ancestors we're gonna
keep moving forward um
and then same with like this winning
idea too um is this not necessarily a
point where you feel like we won uh you
feel we have made progress
i can see this progress both on the map
of all the colors um of this
uh
this ever growing larger deck of cards
that we've filled out um in the fact
that we have higher abilities and now we
can tackle these higher level cards uh
so i'm i'm with this design kind of
trying to move away from that
binary of a winner and a loser and kind
of reframe what that looks like for for
legacy games
hope that helps
thank you so much
[Applause]